you
Fisher random it's good to be white on
chest cube because you get time to think
and your time isn't ticking I want to
take all day right here all day not
really let's start out with this because
I love having my night right behind a
pond hmm this can quickly turn into a
very normal looking position let's do
that sneak attack on the rook okay Black
is uh inconvenience by having to play
the square because this night now is
scratching his head he wonders where his
home is going to be 0 0 for a second I
thought this Bishop would come here and
give check that is that is not my king
there there is no fear of a bishop
giving check if he gets to a 4 so my
plan here is to Fein keto I want to
Castle King sides my night is going to
go here or no no no I don't I don't know
if I really am going to go Kings side
Rodrigo my guests the magic number 47 so
that's why we are doing battle here
let's get my nights out classic squares
who could argue with that control all
four center squares if you have your
nights here and here g3 Bishop g2 or III
Bishop e2 or maybe I reserve my options
let's do this and get my bishop to the
only square that he could go to I'm
trying to be flexible with this move
order having a flexible move order
allows or makes your opponent guests a
little bit more does doesn't it let's do
this in case their IDs of b5 I could
take and win upon exchange Queens first
after eight takes be I'm not worried
about that let me get my bishop here
queen here would threaten this pun look
at her what a sneaky peace bishop here
maybe I do without maybe I do without
now you know I want a counter-attack get
out of there okay now that i'm going to
that's that's a pinned pond so i'm going
to attack it with a pond that's worth a
little bit less than the beep on do i
capture the pinned piece I see no reason
to right away at the Queen gets out of
the pin then I'll snip that pond oh what
a sneaky move so much for that okay well
ah man just pawns gonna capture and this
Queens gonna get this right now that was
a sneaky move Bishop h6 who does that
who moves their bishop twice you
shouldn't be violating these principles
you're supposed to be not considering
this out of the box stuff III night here
and he starts to give me a headache ah
ok let's chop here oh now I have an easy
solution what was I getting all worked
up about Queen takes here I play see 5 I
slammed the door on the Queen I hit the
queen with the note the no soup for you
move c5 is that move no soup for you and
the soup is f2 Bishop g2 next in a very
long castle i also have potential tricks
against the rook over here who's
struggling to do something constructive
i also have this move i could get the
light squared Bishop and then queen here
what do I have as a reply
not much maybe next now we're gonna go
here let's go because I want my bishop
to see the world Queen here do I take
right away or do I play this probably
just take right away fork where is she
going to go this has to be good at the
end of if the Queen has ended up
recapturing on this square I get a six
Queen has a role of watching over a six
what if I do that setting some dangerous
things up my night is within striking
distance by striking distance I mean
checking distance to different squares
good potential check here he's defended
I still can't capture here let's make
sure I long castle there we go i have
all my pieces working and I could look
into moves no not like that the rook is
defended now by the night where I'm
about even 20 seconds difference on the
clock where's the safe home for black
that's not the safe home that's
definitely not a safe home this is a
very good square for my night and now
that this King is running for his life
this pot I time viewing as insignificant
who cares about that pond let's open the
position up I don't care about that pond
grab I want to open the position up and
I was actually missing that my opponent
could take here and I didn't realize
with that sequence of moves my bishop
was shut out of the game why didn't I
see that I think it should still be
quite alright I this pond is not going
anywhere this night is stuck although I
could play here now plays here I take
this night is not he doesn't have any
good home he doesn't have any squares
neither does this just realizing these
two details important details neither of
these pieces can move this night can't
move too far so I could take here and
now this night again can't move rook
here I guess is needed but now i'm
really looking to hack away at that
d7 pond with simple doubling maybe even
tripling up on the D file my worst piece
is my bishop on g2 the night here is
defended and now I'm actually
threatening mate oh I had a mate no I
could have taken with my queen Queen
takes rook takes here would have been a
cool finish this was the last square
that the king could maybe go to yeah now
he's running I don't know I just got
this now they cut off the circulation or
the communication there between e5
that's busted no that's a that's a night
down and soon to be a rip down yeah I
had one move earlier I didn't have to
double my rooks on the D file i had
Queen takes d5 Queen takes Queen and
then rook takes on d7 mate again after
that move so this queen is pinned it's
not really going to matter much here let
me just take and now I'll take this pawn
I'm threatening tricky stuff here and
just the capture of the night so this is
this is the mopping up phase have a
material edge and on the keep it
squeaky-clean here super super simple
that's a discovered check keep it simple
do not complicate things and now chase
that rook away so I could grab the night
there's no fear of any back rank stuff
either I was at Bishop block pawn push
f3 anything at this point
it's going to be mate mate in three one
two three or one all right good game
Rodrigo what I was just ready to close
out let's go back I think my first quick
point is to don't try it try your best
not to be inconvenienced by this threat
if if you can still develop a piece and
meet my threat certainly consider it and
so what I'm getting at is Knight f6 is
likely much better it became very
awkward for you to complete development
by play when you had a pawn on f6 and
maybe that's my main point and maybe
maybe a suggestion for myself is to stop
thinking about playing a single square
and maybe I can already start to look
into taking advantage of my lead and
development it's a slight one but it's
still there it's still present d for
welcoming more exchanges maybe this was
a little bit better on my part but d
three isn't bad and like I was saying
during the game this idea of keeping
flexibility with d3 Bishop d2 and I'm
still not sure I'm not showing my hand
with where I will develop my bishop will
it be III Bishop e2 or g3 Bishop g2 I
waited on that and I spent I I got a
little too nervous here and finally I
realized that this is a perfectly fine
response this game i think is already
close to maybe being over there's just a
big it's not harmonious on the black
side and I'm two moves away from having
all my pieces working this is a
potential target this is a potential
vulnerability since he's unprotected and
my queen is my queen is essentially
developed without even without having
to have moved just because of the
certain potted van pond advances that
took place my a pond running up to a
five it's a way to develop your rooks in
a regular chess game where they're
starting on the ARH files advancing the
rec ponds are making exchanges just all
of a sudden now they're developed but
yeah I think this is already dating back
it may sound weird but it's already
starting to become a bit weird or a bit
awkward for this f64 for you to complete
development when you're playing f6
instead of something more natural that's
that's one of the big things that i'm
looking into when i'm playing these
fisher random games is how can i how can
I organize my pieces in a way where
things remain harmonious and that that's
that's really what you're needing to do
I think because if you're not there's
big trouble around it seems every corner
and c6 well again I think it's still
just very difficult at this point but
this is just giving my night a great
home open the position when you have a
leading development and this was the
last point I was saying during the game
after rook to d8 I do have Queen takes
Knight Queen takes Queen rook takes pawn
would be made but didn't quite see that
in time alrighty good game Rodrigo
you